- party time baby
if it's not h3 is over then its YouTube
is over party and if it's not YouTube is
over party then its its ilysm actual
birthday party which was yesterday
happy birthday ela thank you so many
party that is hard to keep track of them
all these days you know I think you do
cap Tara and stamps for sponsoring our
episode today ela how was your birthday
you're now 32 years old and I can
officially say you're now a MILF my
birthday was great thanks to you you're
welcome
you really went all out and I appreciate
it got lots of gifts you're 32 right yes
so was it a meme that the numbers were
wrong in the picture there was a typo
somewhere along the way someone help me
arrange everything and she got the she
mixed up the numbers little enough yeah
but I mean come on what am I gonna what
am I gonna do not take a photo of it
well thank you you're welcome
you deserve it you really do um you know
it was annoying to be honest with you I
bought some stuff for you like literally
three weeks ago and that mother freaking
crap only arrived today and the other
one didn't even arrived yet I'm like
dude what's going on in this world so I
don't know I mean but at school my
birthday continues it's not cool are you
trying to make of it but I'm pissed
I had this such a cute day like we had
this day out we're gonna get lunch
we wouldn't got a massage and then I had
dinner plan and I was gonna I had four
gifts for her and I was gonna give them
to her throughout the day but I only
ended up having two of them and the
other to the dinner arrived yet were
like the main surprise guests so I
wouldn't have been so cute to be like
good morning here's a gift oh did you
enjoy lunch there's a gift oh did you
enjoy the massage here's a gift Oh
dinner here's another gift and every
time you would have been like oh oh
oh but Ethan showed me all the gifts
even the ones to dinner I've and you
like nailed it 1000% exactly stuff that
I love which is pretty cool because I'm
gonna be tough like my mom cannot buy me
stuff
what sister can't buy me stuff they all
know they just know they're not even
gonna try they don't spend as much time
with you as I do that was very cool no
I'm glad I nailed it love everything
the earrings you're wearing if you
listen to this like heavy metal jewelry
kind of [ __ ] the necklace I bought is
similar to that one too it's all about
that chain maybe
so anyway happy birthday to ela the next
party is the YouTube is over party very
exciting pack it up everybody yeah the
next day after our last podcast there
was a new over party it was pretty funny
I wish
ela had said we wish we left up the
decoration yeah the kpop canceling us
because we could have left that up for
YouTube now so what did YouTube do you
know YouTube really is almost as like a
birthday for them because I feel like
they get canceled every year it's almost
like an annual celebration so really it
is kind of like their birthday it is a
holiday season let's remember when did
this take place the beginning of
December so let's see if next year
there's another YouTube is over party
around the same time of year
what did YouTube do YouTube enacted a
new anti harassment policy that resulted
in the removal of several prominent
videos beloved videos including for
example most prominent I would say as
idubbbz content cop on leafyishere as we
all know and love and cherish that video
it's really like a historical video at
this point of an era
yeah totally it's a it totally is and I
mean if anything it belongs in a museum
not off YouTube yeah they should put
that in the honored video's catalog of
YouTube you know what I mean you should
have like a page
specifically dedicated to the most
honored videos on YouTube now I'll get
into that later but let's let's get into
the policy itself here's the blog post
they posted and let me dig into this for
you here we go now I'm gonna read you
guys some bulletin points but here it is
they say an update to our harassment
policy yeah it's too much to read read
YouTube rewind
oh let's see can I read this whole thing
not really no there's no it's not that
interesting it's just here I okay but
here I'll I'll give you the Reader's
Digest YouTube will no longer allow
videos that maliciously insult someone
based on protected attributes such as
race gender identity or sexuality I feel
like they already didn't allow that me
too because they had a anti-hate policy
yeah but um maybe I'm wrong I don't know
cuz here it doesn't yeah I mean it says
right yeah you couldn't say racist [ __ ]
before could you well and they did and
that's what kind of kicked off this
whole controversy back in the summer
with the Crowder and the Vox dude right
yeah because the Vox dude was saying hey
your policy says that he should be
banned for these things and you're not
doing it so I'm not sure what exactly
they expanded on because they definitely
had an anti I hate policy I guess it's
specifically about harassment maybe
you're not committing a hate crime but
it's more about I don't know it's it's
funny that they have to make up these
rules for themselves I know I feel like
just you don't have to justify someone
is maliciously insulting someone based
on race or gender that's a yeah it's
just like common sense isn't it yeah I
think so and and I think that I just
find it funny that they need to create
these rules when the rule itself is so
broad and could be enforced in ways that
are really up for interpretation as well
look at the examples of videos that also
remove they're actually posting blogs I
always say that to them I'm like hey I
go bro what why are you late toasting
blogs you're
you're a video platforming you guys
can't even make videos to announce this
[ __ ] you're supposed to be like so
progressive and it's a video platform
nobody reads yet like the future blogs
feel like that's I don't even hear that
in water rain yeah a blog you mean a
vlog I mean a vlog right YouTube will
also ban implied threats of violence
which again seems like something that
they probably already did implied
threats of violence like I'm gonna
[ __ ] kill this guy a row erupted in
June so this is I think what many people
point to as the genesis for this new
harassment policy a row erupted in June
after a prominent video maker said he
had been the target of abuse by another
youtuber at the time YouTube said its
rules had not been broken but it has now
deleted many of those videos in question
out what they're talking about is a
steven crowder which here I have a was
kept referencing to this reporter for
Vox whose name is gay wonk by the way on
Twitter and I feel like I shouldn't be
saying that but that is his name on
Twitter so I was like that can I say gay
wonk so Dan explained to me that a walk
is like a political junkie but a walk
almost sounds like a epithet like a
racial slur you walk I was thinking like
a wank ok wank no you can't say that you
can't say gay wank how dare you well the
wank is like a right no he's a gay
Lincoln and jokin he's a gay wonk that's
his Twitter handle I mean it feels wrong
to say though but anyway regardless he
says I so this is back in May 30th and
he says so I have a pretty thick skin
when it comes to online harassment but
something has been really bothering me
since I started working at box steven
crowder has been making video after
video debunking strikethrough I guess
that's this series every single video
has included repeated over attacks on my
sexual orientation and ethnicity let's
watch the the this was a huge thing I
think we
yeah we covered and so at the time I'll
show you this video but at the time
YouTube responded what the [ __ ] is this
it's phone number
oh he got Docs I got dog stand people
were yeah that sucks that's happened to
me I know that shitty that is but anyway
YouTube responded by saying while we
think this content is respectable it
doesn't break any of our rules so we're
unable to act which was like whoa I
think like that was a ballsy play
because every I think that pissed
everybody off you know but now they have
rules so all these videos by Crowder
were removed but anyway here's what
crowd is said about the gay wonk video
with our favorite favorite and listen
it's ridiculous it's bonkers you're
being given a free pass as a crappy
writer because you're gay that's
Federline on his a little queer graph
there payments like you've been given a
pass as being a shitty writer because
you're gay I mean that's is that
harassment I guess I guess what he's
showing is the repeated like I mean I
appreciate it was just that this is what
mr. gay Vox wants to do mister let's be
queer from Vox what were you holding gay
latino from Potts fast motion is gay I'm
not sure why this guy on the gay semi
Latino vote with this spray anymore okay
he's a sachets across without eight like
just stop that gay Vox pretory like a
fairy wispy means my sprite why does he
keep calling him a sprite I hadn't
really heard that one before and is a
fairy yeah like a fairy I guess yes
he's really he likes that sprite and so
on Fox Freeman trying
you by the way the gay Mexican guy gay
latino v-neck gay Mexican Mexican gay
guy used to work Mexican gay latino
there at that bottle gay Latino friend
Bobby told me he's boxing
he's definitely obsessed with this guy
sexuality is this great gay I mean I'm
getting kind of Gabe eyes from Crowder
that he wants to [ __ ] gay wonk so
obsessed with the sexuality I think
correct I think Crowder is into mr.
Carlos here you know you're not the
first one to I mean it's kind of
outrageous it's like dude maybe you
should just suck a dick and see if you
like it I guess am i am i harassing
Crowder now no and I'll tell you why
because I don't make comments if I
started every podcast was saying I think
Crowder needs to suck a dick and see if
he likes it because I think he's gay
that might be harassment but I don't
know I guess it would be right
according to YouTube this case is
definitely definitely seems like a
problem well it's malicious that's for
sure not really cool and I can see how
that would invite like really awful
comments from his viewers like people
who watch this there's there's there's
something that he's saying between the
lines
yeah about this guy Carlos that and at
least according to him it's not just
could it it did right yeah like he got
ducks by his followers well I'm not
surprised if I was you know if I was
part of this guys fan base or well
people are crazy right we all agree on
that especially ones who are fanatic
about things so if I was a fanatic
person of Crowder's then I can see me
taking this way too far because he's
really building him I was like a
boogeyman but regardless that's what
started it at the time YouTube said hey
we can't do anything about this well
they crafted the new rules and they can
now do something about it so they
removed all the videos talking about
about that reporter
and apparently people are well into yeah
prior to the changes YouTube had already
banned videos that contain explicit
threats of violence bullied someone
about their parents revealed somebody's
personal information encouraged viewers
to harass an individual but the new
policy also bans veiled or implied
threats of violence such as saying you
better watch out that's my you better
watch or you say what would you say
watch out watch out oh you can say that
I don't think anyone takes you seriously
I don't think yours is a veiled threat
it's an outright threat simulated
violence towards an individual malicious
insults based on protected attributes
such as race gender and sexual
orientation
oops ed the new policy will apply to
everyone including politicians popular
YouTube stars as well as general public
video makers who consistently break the
rules will have their ability to earn
advertising revenue restricted and may
have videos deleted or their channel
closed the company said there will be
some exemptions from the new policy
including insults use and scripted
satire oh well that's interesting
because I feel like I got to bring that
up yeah later in this bit remember they
said that exempts including insults used
in scripted satire stand-up comedy or
music yeah so actually funnily enough
now that YouTube is acted on behalf of
gay wonk I just call him by his name
yeah I don't like Carlos maza
it's his Twitter handle I mean the guy
named himself gay walk on Twitter what
am I supposed to do no Dan what do you
guys can I call him gay walk or should I
just call okay
I mean it's sweater Han I mean you're
right it is his Twitter handle but it
seems to be bugging you so just don't oh
yeah great so Carlos from Vox he's
reaction to YouTube's new policy is
extreme skepticism malicious insults
were already prohibited under YouTube's
anti hate and anti-harassment policies
YouTube rolls out policies like this to
distract reporters from the real story
YouTube's not enforcement I did
agreed they or people already moved on
past this I feel like this is not if
they were just trying to do PR that
would have done they would have removed
the videos at the time so I disagree
with him on that one I think YouTube
makes exceptions for popular craters
like Crowder
even when moderators flag they they just
moved all this video so hold on is that
confirmed that they removed all of his
videos I thought he took down all of his
own videos himself oh well I'm sorry
emp'd getting taken down
I actually I don't know I saw somewhere
that all of his videos were removed that
where he talked about him let me because
I read differently but it it seems well
I think try and figure it out right now
because he goes he goes on malicious
insults are only a small part of the
problem on YouTube the bigger problem is
hateful content stuff the target's
entire group spent Schapiro smearing
Muslims as terrorists lauren southern
railing against mass migration this is
HB with a smile see that that to me is a
very slippery slope a kind of really I
don't know I that I could I just have to
strongly disagree with I mean Ben
Shapiro was entitled to have a whether
you agree with him or not you should be
able to talk about he's saying I can't
discuss Muslim is a bit his take on like
a religion cuz its aid speech I mean I
don't know I mean if this is a huge
topic of conversation Muslims is it gets
really tough if mass migration I mean
dude you you can oppose migration I
don't know that seems kind of insane
that that statement strikes me as
remarkably insane also I mean you just
have to take it step by step they're
doing something so right that's good
like you can't expect everything that
wants to and this is the problem with
kind of these uh for lack of better word
I don't like saying this but like social
justice warriors let's just say for lack
of better word let's say it's never
enough their their mission is always to
push it further and to never be
satisfied I think by the definition of
their their belief system and their
ethnos is that you're always pushing for
change
and you're never satisfied so it's hard
to satisfy these people D monetization
doesn't work on YouTube it never has
people like Crowder make money through
merch sales and direct donations not
Adsense as long as YouTube gives them a
platform
they'll keep breaking the rules your
monetization doesn't work bro that's
wrong
also you just want them to start banning
people that you don't like I'm sorry
dude no I don't know why he just can't
take this as a victory like YouTube
loves to manage PR crisis by rolling up
fake content policies that I'm actually
enforce these photos only work if you
two was willing to take down his most
popular rule breakers and there's no
reason so far to believe that they did
well they did do that as far as I can
tell they removed a lot of very popular
videos as pissing people off and you
know see what then it comes back away
because ya know I'm googling around
trying to figure it out and I can't seem
to find confirmation one way or another
well I mean one thing if you go to his
channel Crowder's channel I mean he's
got a bajillion videos and yes it's not
like he got the platforms or anything no
he didn't get the platform but if they
didn't remove any of his videos if he
took them down first we definitely know
for sure that they did take down a lot
of very famous or I don't know a lot
they took down famous videos so there's
no reason to believe that they wouldn't
I mean especially if this was the
Genesis for this whole role to begin
with
it seems that either he removed them
before the rule went into effect or
YouTube removed them I don't know which
although he did make a video saying that
the purge was coming and I don't know
what the [ __ ] but there's another group
that um Carlos was retweeting called
ban Google from pride who who also
agrees that they haven't gone far enough
well it's great that YouTube says they
are making approve mr. policies which
they have been insisting are already
good enough we don't think these changes
are meaningful many of us have taken to
referring to not just policies but
policies and practices precisely because
existing policies could have been enough
in many cases how you actually enforced
them is far more important well that's
true
um I'm not gonna read this who cares but
you get the idea so on one hand Crowder
Crowder made like an 11 minute long
video about it I guess I should pull
that up to give it the full story I can
you give that video damn it's like funny
how YouTube can never like it seems like
they can never do the right thing at the
right time it's true they're always
having trouble I don't know why at the
moment when it was brought up that he
was making those videos they didn't do
anything it's like a year later now and
now they're doing this and now
everyone's confused like where is this
coming from
mmm it's just a bureaucracy dude like I
always say people think that YouTube is
a huge monolith there's like 20 people
running it seriously and then when they
want to make a policy change there's
lawyers there's PR then they have
different lawyer teams for different
countries because they operate in so
many different countries they have to
it's like it's insane the bureaucracy
behind policy shifts like this huh are
you guys fishing up that crowd or video
I'm talking about the purge one yeah
yeah I just found it hold on there it is
thank you Dan
so you guys saw the Carlos's response so
now here's Crowder's response just and
the you know a lot of people been
talking about a lot of rumors
circulating there's a lot of information
out there some of it true some of it I'm
true gosh I wish I were aging into a
silver fox but instead I just look like
a hobo getting a gray here in - what are
the conservative community and irony but
larger really the YouTube community at
large because as we saw from the recent
controversy it didn't if it wasn't
relegated to only the conservative
community okay
the YouTube purge is happening let me
say that this is something a lot of
people have talked about for a while
December 10th December 11th some new
policies coming down the pike a lot of
people have been concerned ourselves
included it is happening well talk say
something what we did by it
now these Carlos had the dignity of
telling just explaining what he thought
and
wait 9 minutes 30 seconds man come on it
by this channel over the summer and
certainly not sorry for the content that
we've created and that you've come to
enjoy I don't apologize for that but
obviously my heart goes out to if there
are any future conservatives or future
independent voices who are affected
because some people got their feelings
hurt so we do know that this is why the
policies have been created okay I can't
but you get that you get the gist right
created I mean the prayer just come in
here let's see there's wonder if he ever
actually defines what that means cuz
again it's like I'm on a stage right now
oh damn what are you eating what are you
eating chips it sounds like you're
eating ice cream or sometimes like you
got a chip problem I drew your chip a
holic take care of then you stopped and
you stopped smoking and now you got a
chip though I think I'm glad you're
eating chips and not smoking so I'm not
gonna give you hate for that those are
goods Lee yeah you make a good point and
before I cut you off for for chip your
chip offense you make a good point I
mean the purge
if the person here not very affect your
right exactly is this like one merge I
mean I do think that we're not gonna see
this rule and forced very much that's my
feeling it really kind of seems like
nothing really changed like you said
it's like the policy is just kind of
reiterating they're saying its new
policy but how is it different than the
old policy it just I don't I really
don't know I guess well I guess they did
add specific rules like the they said
the part about like they said that
they'll take it as a pattern of behavior
so if maybe they don't break the rules
in one video but if they keep harassing
somebody then they can look at it as a
pattern of behavior called
oh that's harassment we're not gonna
love it anymore you know even if an
individual video doesn't cross our
policy line I think that's yeah that's
new it's a little bit of nuance yeah
so whatever the purge is coming okay so
let's look at for example videos notable
videos that were removed content cop on
leafy was removed and that one shocked a
lot of us in the YouTube community items
tweeted your download your favorite
bowling videos before YouTube takes them
down here's the email he got as you may
know our Community Guidelines describes
calm bro you just put it out I think
that's why as you may know it's like you
just changed it but basically what I
would guess is that it's probably
because he made fun of his look yeah
with the chin so in the case of this
specific video the whole point is that
he was bullying him right
of course it's it's I would hope that
would be more nuanced than that because
the point is that Leif he was a bully if
it was actually one that really was Bo
and so n was making this rhetorical
point this artistic I think there's even
an argument
for an artistic parody yeah which is
what they said what did I say we make
exceptions for parodies cryptid parodies
adapted satire specifically so I think
that he really is making a valid point
and he even says in a video I'm gonna
bully him cuz he's a bully and that's
how you teach bullies yeah and he makes
fun of his looks but okay so YouTube
doesn't have any nuance and so they they
took down that video at least we can say
we know why it was removed even if we
disagree and hope that they have more
nuance you know interestingly none of
his other content cops were removed only
this one yeah it's just weird um people
were joking about how keemstar kept
refreshing it waiting for nothing that
is content cop got removed yeah only
that one was removed interestingly now
this one really I upsetted me and I
didn't get it
Zach psychic pebbles made a video about
the finebros many years ago this
reuploads from 2013 finebros react man
sac was like prophetic because this is
from six years ago mm-hmm these guys are
even more out of control than they were
then and this video was removed can I
not watch it chi not comment on it it
was removed mm-hmm come true so anyway
it's just a joke about how they're
basically milking this one idea for
reactions and they're making a shitload
of money and they're beating a dead
horse I mean it's a beautiful piece of
satire it's really funny and there's
really nothing wrong with it especially
considering that it's a scripted satire
mm-hmm that it's very thoughtful that it
is a specific criticism against them and
it is it's like so it is so clear that
it's satire from the beginning there is
no question I mean here I'll show you
the beginning I don't think they'll
just showing you an excerpt survivors
react Townsend roamers react babies
react and child molesters react what
else can we do we need more ideas the
cash suit is running low I mean you get
the idea
this kind of crisis so and it's
definitely not harassment I mean this is
one videos act number talk about them
again so this video was removed when
they wrote out the new policy and I'm
stuck here wondering the video is
extraordinarily vulgar and I would
understand if it got removed on that
basis but these disavow Garrety existed
before the new rule well just say
age-restricted yeah just age-restricted
why we I don't know it's it really sucks
because that was just such a again such
a great piece to just mark to just
dismiss it as harassment I think is it's
disappointing feel like this this one is
such a typical set are like why even if
you were a fan of that channel you can
still watch this and laugh at it like
you know I mean it's not harassment it's
just a funny
exaggeration or that they're just
exactly like the finebros i wouldn't
imagine that they would be so offended
by this video yeah I would hope not but
there you have it so I don't know I find
that really uh quite disappointing and
well I don't really know what to say
about that I just I find it concerning
that this was one of the ones removed
but besides these two are kind of the
most notable in terms of what I'm aware
of so there wasn't that many yeah I
didn't have any removed by the way which
is kind of I expected to have a couple
removed on her I was like oh [ __ ] when
we check my emails see what got got but
nada
I mean I'd like to think that we're not
bullying anyone well I don't think zach
is bullying anyone either
but there you have it you've been had a
video about the fine brothers I did
you know if I definitely had a fine
videos finebros it just proves that it's
totally arbitrary like mm-hmm and I made
fun of the way the guy looked at I mean
he's a weird-looking dude and I
definitely talked about that you know I
remember well anyway there is of course
that doesn't mean that there isn't
conspiracy theories by the one-and-only
clowns star who's been on a crusade
against me as he has been for a long
time he's a bit obsessed with me one
might say but we'll talk about that when
we come back from the break and so stay
tuned we will be talking about the
killer clown star when we come back
don't go anywhere
what if you can make your work take less
work you can with kaptara kaptara helps
you find the right software for your
needs fast so you can get back to
business
even faster compare thousands of
software options read reviews and
instantly narrow your favorites you'll
have more time in no time find the right
software right now at kaptara comm / h3
kaptara
is the leading free online resource to
help you find the best software
solutions for your business with over 1
million reviews of products from real
software users discover everything you
need to make an informed decision search
more than 700 specific categories of
software everything from project
management to email marketing and all
the way down yes to yoga studio
management software does it get more
niche than that I don't know but
probably probably probably yes go look
on kaptara I bet you they got it
whatever you need no matter what kind of
software your business needs kaptara
makes it easy to discover the right
solution fast so join the millions of
people who use kaptara each month to
find the right tools for their business
now kaptara is one of those
one-of-a-kind places on the internet
because let's face it we all got this
tedious crap to do we're all
entrepreneurs out here we're all trying
to chase that cheddar and you don't know
what perfect software is out there this
is gonna make your life so much easier
for example we search the kaptara and we
were able to find a it was really a
content management system for managing
tasks back here so I can slave dr ian
even better I'll make sure that he
doesn't forget tasks and now enos 10 20
times more productive than he ever was
any boy he is earning that salary
thank you to kaptara visit kaptara comp
/hz for free today to find the tools to
make an informed software decision for
your business cap Terry Cobbs / h3
kaptara
that's CA p ter ra I feel like I said
the pacing was weird but it's CA p ter
ra comm / h3 kaptara
software selection simplified
when I talk about stamps.com I always
wonder ela who in the world still goes
to the post office and why Winston thank
you
when stamps.com brings the post office
to you no need to interrupt your day
with a flood with a fight with traffic
to get to the post office there's come
on there's a million reasons not to go
there especially now during the holidays
when the post office is extra busy with
people sending holiday cards and gift
that's why you need to head on over to
stamps calm anything you do at the post
office you can do it stamps calm saps
calm eliminates trips to the post office
and saves you money with discounts that
you can't even get at the post office
that's right steps are cogs bring all
the services of the US Postal Service
right to your computer whether your
small office sending invoices or an
online sellers shipping out product or
even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day Sam saw comp can handle
it all with ease simply use your
computer to print official US postage
24/7 for any letter any package any
class of mail anywhere you want to send
what's your mail is ready you just hand
it to your mail carrier or drop it in a
mailbox it's that simple with stamps.com
you get five cents off every first-class
stamp and up to 40% off Priority Mail
not to mention it's a fraction of the
cost of those expensive postage meters I
still don't know what's a postage meter
but I'm assuming enough people do that
it's worth reading does anyone know what
a postage meter is maybe that's what uh
I'm not gonna now is not the time either
Sam so calm is a no-brainer saving you
time and money
it's no wonder over 700 thousand small
businesses already use stamps calm don't
spend a minute of your holiday season at
the post office this year sign up for
stamps , said there's no risk and with
my promo code h3 you get a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitment or contract once
again just go to stamps com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in h3 that stamps comm and
enter h3 stamps are calm never go to the
post office again
welcome back
how are the ads everybody did you have a
good time Dan hiding we were talking in
the bathroom that um you have never peed
during the break what's up with that
somebody's got a hold hold it down do
you have to pee are you just holding it
down sometimes I actually do right now
really can't just leave this whole
operation unattended well the coffee is
rolling so somebody's got to make sure
it's not [ __ ] up so I got to give it
up to Dan the wizard back there honestly
congratulations that Dan was holding it
holding it down and holding it in mm-hmm
so we were talking about killer keemstar
who was of course and the absence of
evidence willing as always to perpetrate
conspiracy theories about me wouldn't be
the first time
keemstar is obsessed with me he really
is really he has yeah and I think that I
mean well
besides me openly you didn't like him
yeah he has a he has a problem his
fragile little clown heart was hurt when
we did the podcast and then I said
afterwards in a comment that I hated him
even though in the podcast itself I
repeatedly tell him how much I disliked
him to his [ __ ] face and by the way
one of the criticisms I got from that
podcast is that I was too openly hostile
to him there you go but then because I
was pleasant to him a backstage and gave
his it gave him it was pleasant and
cordial then I'm a snake polite yeah was
polite so I'm a snake because anyway he
can't get over that which is crazy but
there it is
I mean I'm not surprised Kim starts one
of those people that he's just so he's
just hard to even imagine he's a real
person you know it's like Tam there's a
real person out there like that it's
wild anyway he goes most so first of all
he says and remember he considers
himself a newsman so take that and call
texts with how insane these accusations
are most videos criticizing you tags me
when you were 100 percent messing up
about a year ago have been removed from
YouTube deemed as harassment okay well I
said to him and then he cites this one
video that was removed for harassment
he says correct me if I'm wrong but
didn't you have a meeting with Susan
earlier this year so that's his evidence
of this massive conspiracy now I said to
him I challenge you to show me one
additional video other than this one
that was removed and it was crickets but
like imagine you're a newsman okay
and how insane you have to be to make
such a [ __ ] blanketly wrong and
malicious statement
I mean slanderous really most of the
videos criticizing you were removed no
one so you really think that Susan the
CEO of YouTube came here to meet us to
talk about you and another guy that made
a video about it
really you think that's how she uses her
time he's obsessed with me dude yeah you
wanna know how I met here and we talked
about some guy that we don't know that
made a video about us that makes a CEO
of YouTube came out to hear me [ __ ]
about that and by the way I'll tell you
how it happened my contact at YouTube
said hey do you want to meet Susan and I
said sure that's it no way no I'm
telling you bro is she Jewish cuz I
don't really think she is oh no she is
Jewish then they're really let's find
out Susan Wojcicki
I don't think she's Jewish thank God
because I would never hear the end of
the Jewish conspiracy theories but if
you follow the same logic born to Esther
was John ski an educator of Russian
Jewish descent
you are Russian Jewish descent
aren't you Ethan Am I I think you are I
don't think I'm Russian I am NOT okay I
think I'm a stringer well I have and she
talked to dad
yep by the same logic of Kiev clown star
the genius news man that means that
leafy also complained to Susan Wojcicki
to remove idubbbz video came to live his
mom's basement
yeah and they had a very important
meeting yeah
my son is being harassed so okay and
then and then furthermore I says okay
well what video is this the death of
Atreus reproductions this video was
removed and if I look into it for more
than just two seconds you'll remember I
said there was a new rule said that it
includes content simulating violence so
if I have to just take a hairbrained gas
it probably wasn't a conspiracy it was
probably just the fact that he has a gun
up to my head like to execute me no not
possible and so as a newsman you think
that you would look 2 seconds into this
before tweeting out some absolutely
psychotic I mean I mean sight he he's so
psycho he's obsessed with trying to ruin
me won't ruin me I mean this has always
been my problem with him is so
irresponsible with the nonsense that he
spreads how it like that just he doesn't
even think about it twice know what he
know he the news is secondary to trying
to hurt or anyone anyone in his way
yeah at that moment it would be anyone
then the new he's just he's there as a
as a weapon to harm people he doesn't
like that's like his M that's what he's
there to do and so I think that keemstar
is a dangerous psychopath I think that
he is a I think he probably has a small
penis as well I could just tell he's
he's a big guy and he's probably really
tiny uh
- you're easy you have a soundbite of
Ian saying that something about a huge
[ __ ] Ian forbid him from using any what
it's just funny it's relevant go ahead I
didn't hear it clean this is all the
soundbite I'm not actually talking
well sorry Kim apparently uh apparently
you have a massive penis so apologies I
recant my my statement I'm gonna go deep
so anyway keemstar found the image again
the excellent news man he's such a
genius watch this Susan Wojcicki h3h3
I bet I bet it shows up let's see well I
can I can run my own news network bro oh
he is a genius because you had it
removed from the Google search results
you also asked her to do that the genius
researcher yeah I mean really we made
her once a week you know she doesn't a
lot you probably had the picture saved
on his hard drive under Ethan hedge ah
yeah anyway yeah anyway Kim it's not us
it's you yeah it's not us I gotta go I
gotta get the sugar ray gotta make a
video well anyway I I responded to him
only and to give honor to this video we
made it's so good about clown clown star
by the way just just to show you guys
because again the crux of his statement
is that most of the videos about me have
been removed and so I says he keeps
going answer the question I says does a
baseless insane conspiracy theory
require an answer you said all videos
critical of me were removed can you list
even one additional video that was taken
down about me and then I said to him
because
asking each other rhetorical questions
cloud star tell me how many balls can
you juggle at once and I think that's a
vowel quite and I don't know why he
hasn't answered me yeah how many balls
can you juggle at once and came a clown
star I know you're watching this cuz
you're obsessed with me you're on every
word and your blood is boiling you're
thinking to yourself how am I gonna
destroy him how am I gonna make a
Twitter rant and then find some [ __ ]
this guy literally got it I don't need
to keep going on about keemstar but it's
not the first time he's just made
actually slanderous lies about me but
that is that and he is a [ __ ] mmm so
here's the video we made to give glory
to to the clown star about where the F
is the Edit where is the edit here it is
dead air clown star
[Music]
[Music]
there's Witter video players I want to
show you the new studio I love the new
studio that's constant for you it's a
beautiful thing beautiful thank you and
there you have it
now he said of course do I need a good
do must I go on that was it I think we
and that's another shoe we can put in
the Box I'm all right mmm-hmm
but I share the concerns of the
community I also I'm worried that it's
so open for justification even for and
yes just real quick I just can you just
answer the question I mean did you ask
Susan take down the video I don't
understand why you can't just answer the
question
I will answer the question damn team
star tells me how many balls you can
juggle at one okay I'm gone if he once
he answers the question that I will
answer the question so there you have it
where were we
I share the concerns of the community I
[Music]
also am worried about how open for
interpretation the rulers like Zacks
video is just so baseless items video
was like at least like I I guess it
follows their rules because he's bowling
him but you would think there would be
more nuance and thought than that but at
the same time they also say that they
have an exception for scripted Seth
so I don't know why that doesn't get I
don't want Ian videos to get taken down
but I mean
if that one got taken down they should
have all been taken down right that's
what doesn't make it that specific one
was more focused on bowling leafy
because you he was bullying other people
like Ethan described right which is why
and it like they I mean it just shows
they didn't look at it not even a minute
further than just what's on surface you
know look what I think happened is that
YouTube had a short list of videos that
have been massively reported for
harassment okay and then they probably
removed most of those videos that's I
think that's all that happened you know
I already had a queued up before yeah
they definitely did because they all
came down immediately right they
definitely had a predestined a list of
videos to remove but I'm curious what
other ones were removed because as far
as I'm aware idubbbz Zach's and then
that one conspiracy the one that
keemstar says I got removed are the only
three that I know of that I've seen
people talking mostly when people have
been done so if you guys are aware of
other ones I'd love to hear about it
because I want to assess this new rule
further to empirical evidence if we can
get it yeah if somebody knows for sure
if Crowder's videos actually got taken
down yeah email us about that because
it's still really big I can't seem to
get a concrete answer on that anywhere
on the internet by the way I love this
the insinuation that keemstar keeps
saying that I'm like the biggest rat in
the world so why wouldn't I just lie to
him about it if I am such a rat why does
he think I'm compelled to even tell him
the truth even if I did do you know what
I'm saying are you do are you asking a
logical question right now I was
attempting to yes okay so too far trying
to apply that to yeah
okay let's move on so that's that Papa
John baby DJ so there's good news on the
Papa John front Papa John is apparently
still thriving in China this was just a
fan that said this to you directly to us
is like a sit-down restaurant I guess
the news hasn't hit China yet news
travels slow Papa John Papa said what
China though hasn't come to China Papa
John put out a new instace story I love
these check this [ __ ] out listen
carefully to what he says
I met a few fans walking down the street
in Florida now listen carefully this is
epic
I love how it bounces I heard pizza yeah
I deserve pizza did where did you record
that damn and I love Papa John's cameras
my favorite [ __ ] but I love at the end
how he bounces like all right well I got
to be going now guys see you later okay
there's a disclaimer on the video it
says apologizing for the poor sound
quality I mean they were aware yeah the
fact that it was completely inaudible
anyways pas I wonder who's taking all
these videos for ya someone is wait how
long screws him with him mm-hmm
but then there was a really solid chub
and tuck as well from the same mm-hm
look at Papa killing it you still
addressed like as if he's working at the
kitchen you know what I mean dude look
at that
look my dudes that's some [ __ ] snatcher
[ __ ] right there boy huh mm-hmm well
that's the shirt say it says everything
better with Papa John's hmm he's still
out there promoting this like like a
movement shirt that he made you know I
think that's I think that's official
merch
no I love it
look how much higher his pants are than
ever there's his fit he's like a little
tiny bit taller not really cuz they're
leaning over but you see where his
waistline is and then look where their
waistline is well cuz he's doing there
over in the Tuck like the Tuck over the
tummy tuck over the tummy there's like
that under talkin there's no he's going
up all the way yeah what are they those
blue shirts
yeah just occurred to me these are
Domino's colors no no no I mean it looks
like they're wearing ah wait is he
flexing on Domino's mmm interesting you
know if you were gonna do this bulb or
native flex on Domino's you better get
the audio right WoW is that a domino it
is that I just noticed it what
man it could just be the same no I think
it is Domino's I think he's trying to
flex on Domino's or he wants a I'm in a
pizza category I have pizza experience I
have pizzas experience yeah here's a
good one you you know there's lots of
news and brexit everybody wants to yeah
here that's definitely the shirt we've
got the Domino's shirt for comparison
sorry had that collab going there it is
I think that's there's indisputably well
there wasn't a black there was like text
on the mmm that's questionable I'm out
I'm out I'm over it
you know Briggs it's a hot topic in
England so the Conservative Party on
Twitter verified its we don't make no
mistake get Berg's it done they
misspelled it and they're freaking flyer
and they said make no mistake it seems
like it's possible Joe what's the joke I
don't know get Berg's it done I guess
the joke is that they said no mistake
and then they made a mistake but why
would they want him look like I do it I
don't know they haven't taken it down
yeah they haven't taken I had I hate to
deliver bad news but it doesn't look
like dominos I'm looking close ok let's
go back to that hold on if you look at
the video okay I'm anyway I just did it
doesn't look like it okay okay I got
word he was conspiring with the enemy
the video then since we've got the
verdict here cuz you can zoom in on the
video man how did you find the two dudes
with the most locally all my shirts ever
say no oh yeah it's not that yeah it
looks like a who knows just some work
here try to decipher what he's saying
like a chainsaw going on they deliver
something they'd mattress they deliver
mattress something about pizza [ __ ]
out dude Papa come on dude
what else we got okay let's talk about
the banana taped to the wall tell me
here's a story you told me does this
make the banana thing more genius or
less genius here are people protesting
janitors who are underpaid are using the
banana to as a symbol is a banana worth
more than us what do we have to do tape
bananas to ourselves and that's just
what they did to make a point about
their perceived value I work two jobs
that can't afford Christmas presents
here they are with bananas taped to them
thoughts you're the art student I like
this ladies they're pretty funny you
feel bad for that I like it I don't know
what to say I don't know talk to the
person who bought that banana but
clearly it says is having a cultural
impact right keep talking about the
banana on the wall I mean that's what
that's what the artist I feel like is
good at like making art that is creating
a big statement and a conversation
around it do you think of D legitimizes
him if he pocketed $120,000 for it no he
got paid he's a famous artist they
didn't get paid so there you don't I
mean if there's anyone to mock as the
person who paid for it right in my
opinion not the person who made it
interestingly there was 1200 janitors in
the area and which is a multiple of
120,000 oh how crazy is that
bananas are lined the bananas aligned
with the amount of protesters that's a
very American that's all that's all
about on that story great story
thank you very much how long we've been
going down 4550 minutes but by the way
they say something they're like our I
know it's something that people don't
value they look at us
like we're nothing but it's a job with
dignity and it's tough work we deserve
better and I agree I agree too I think
it is a job I want you to clean I think
it's in it and then yeah cleaning people
or just treated like they're not even
there I think all jobs have dignity I
think for someone to get up go to work
do some [ __ ] there's already dignity I
think there's too much job shaming in
this country you get up you go to
McDonald's you work there
that's a job you know what I'm saying
yeah you got that's a thankless job you
got a deal with so many people I think
all jobs have dignity and I personally
do subscribe to the notion that that
generally speaking I think jobs should
provide a livable wage for the people
that work yeah even if it is McDonagh
that is part of why I like yank I like
his idea of giving $1000 to every genius
I like it and I like Bernie because he
always says we got to raise the minimum
wage and he like he really cares about
this people I think burnt
I love Bernie I like it and I I'll tell
you why I love yang though I think the
thousand dollars per person is such a
genius way of attacking poverty and even
homelessness right like if you have like
there's a huge homeless epidemic in LA
if you incentivize them each to $1,000 a
month that's gonna get their ass off the
street and also it might get them out of
LA to a more affordable place where you
could actually pay rent you could pay
rent for $500 a month and also then
these people are gonna go live somewhere
they can have their own house yeah and
[Music]
Danny's going through the bathroom I got
a piece so bad historic moment on the
show let's just have dead air till he
comes back here should we should thought
Dan go just show me an empty chair yeah
[ __ ] you tell fun Dan what can you say
why I'm not gonna say about Dan that
that we wouldn't say to his face
hmm he's an Android
we talked about his chip problem is what
chips problem oh I think it's funny
hi I'm afraid that he thinks I'm
actually giving him a hard time
I think it's hilarious no I'm actually
worried that he's working some kind of
new addiction there with the chips hmm
you guys you see I mean how often you
see eating chips is this something he
does on the air uh he doesn't eat a lot
yeah probably more on the air what is it
I'm just trying to ham it up yes I mean
it's kind of a meme now yeah it's just
so funny to open the mic chewing it's
like dude what the hell it's great I
don't know maybe he associates like
beeping with the show so he's like man
he used to have a part and now he's a
good old boy unicorn cheese a still walk
in here it smelled like a carnival like
legit
it smelled like calm and I was like damn
carnival yeah like that thank you alone
he's a great guy we love Dan yeah Dan an
extraordinary individual no bomb packed
that he he's a wizard he knows his [ __ ]
I hate this really Dan like hey then can
I put something from my laptop and then
I want you to be able to put on your
foot and then I want to put something
from that laptop at home
and and then Papa John was like no but
you're right and that what you're saying
and then basically the next week I come
and you got it all configured and we can
do what I asked ya to do exactly you got
we should give a tour of the back so
people can see like that's true
the how why did Ian Swiss to me when I
came back let's go ahead what's going on
here
it's true I don't ask Ian I don't know
what do you asking me I don't know what
he is doing I never know what he is
doing back there with the live switch
tell me why tell me why doesn't he
answer himself when he talks
nobody knows nobody and I have to tell
you although I think you're a great
switcher I'm a little bit concerned
because we don't hear from you anymore
and I think that that's a problem mm-hmm
well what's the point of talking you'll
just soundbite what I said
maybe we should chill back on the
soundbite he's got a pretty there's some
real frustration I'm gonna say okay yeah
maybe we should show that because I do
want to hear from me in yeah how are you
in don't touch don't do it don't do it
I'm fine I also think Ian is an
extraordinary me too ian is a fantastic
he's a fantastic young man yeah he's not
hard talented multi-talented he just got
a raise to so massive penis there you go
yeah there you go
you see we use the soundbite who's
honored Ian to honour you how big is it
in your not talking so at least you know
we couldn't hear your voice at least a
little bit used to be so vocal on the
show I mean you don't do segments for us
anymore
what what what a war wars there's
powerpoints dude I think we need a
PowerPoint a month at least I totally I
completely agree Rhoda
what do we ask you for once a month if
you have anything to say for yourself I
mean again Zak's about that a soundbite
in the Brinkley I don't blame her I
gotta pee so bad a tear after your easy
penis you forgot one more candy
ah come on Zach all right it's so are
you requesting no more sound bites you
can use them out of chair it's fine but
I want to hear from you that's not true
I'll lay off but I'll use them sparingly
well I thought that the use of the penis
one was very good and the same says but
dan dan is disputing that you don't care
so would you like to say anything in
your defense or in contrast to what Dan
said
well no it's just every time I open my
mouth it's a sound bite so I'm like okay
you guys can do it the e'en by if you
want that's fine we should build a and I
think if we do the N bot we should have
a segment yeah where it's like I'm gonna
talk to fake and yeah but I want to hear
from real in as well and I don't want to
discourage real in from commenting on
things mm-hmm um-hmm we're in a pickle
here well here we've got a couple more
stories here I'm kind of I'm ready to
take I'm ready to walk away it was your
birthday I want to go spend time with
Theodore you know it's already three I
barely saw that sweet little kid he's
sitting up now oh yeah yeah he's sitting
up by the way he's getting teeth in I to
like let him chew on my finger when he
cuz he liked the feeling on his gums
when he's teething and recently I put it
in his mouth and he caught me with his
tooth and I was like he almost took my
finger off [ __ ] it's crazy
he's so cute he's so cute and he's got
these little toys where he um obviously
he can't he's not close to be able to
walk but when you put him in these
walking toys like a walker
he's like a lightning you know he's a
danger on the road
he's crazy out there he doesn't want to
crawl he just wants to walk but it's not
very student crawling at all you know
you are Dan are you saying you want to
talk about the Weinstein thing uh yeah
oh yeah this is great Weinstein reached
a Weinstein Weinstein or Weinstein
Weinstein reached a 25 million dollar
settlement with 30 women 30 women that's
so many women or even Perot that's
insane that's so many oh my god yeah
not a good guy turns out I would hope
that they would get more than that you
know
like that's less than a milli per pop
this guy's this guy's got cheddar I mean
what's he worth
Harvey Weinstein net worth his net was
probably plummeted a little bit but 50
million breathing whoo that's gonna hurt
him actually he real cuz he's not paying
for it company is it says he is now
worth 50 but he used to be worth 300 so
who knows hmm yeah I love that the
company is actually paying that arts
insurance I don't know and he showed up
to a court in a walker which is like the
classic I seen this [ __ ] so many times
it's just so awesome
I love the tennis balls like they really
went for authenticity
well Walker what is that that's a real
why I've always wondered what's with the
tennis balls I think I could not yeah I
could see an old lady doing that do not
always be a tennis ball but you're
really telling me Harvey did that they
probably just like nobody's been old but
why haven't they found a better better I
mean I guess nobody thought of anything
better than a tennis ball why don't they
just make them with a non scratch thing
at the bottom but my heart is not that
simple
it's got ten I just find that so funny
anyway here's Bev for just for the
record here's Bill walking into court he
did the same thing with the Walker look
at poor Bill Cosby oh he's roofied
anyone in prison contraband in the jello
and then did you find the one I
requested from well anyway there was a
dishes documentary called the not-see
next door oh I looked for that I
couldn't I think his Netflix thing it's
pretty locked down so this guy did the
same thing it's funny they they tried
him for Nazi war crimes and the FBI was
surveilling him so they had footage of
him the day before just chilling with
his family and walking around I know
it's a it's an awesome war criminal it
says documented called the Nazi next
door it's really interesting really good
but anyway so the day before he's like
just walking around totally fine and
then the next day in court it's like Oh
in a wheelchair and he's like comatose
you know it's it's like the oldest the
oldest play in the book but this is
great look how sad this pathetic old
yeah it is what the tennis balls man
that really ties it
well how pathetic do you need to be just
put the Walker way have some dignity man
yeah well I guess dignity is out the
door at this point I like the premise
that it's like sir you've been accused
of 30 counts of sexual harassment but
now that I see you with the Walker
I'm gonna go lenient on you there you
have it that's all I have to say about
that in the words of force count I guess
the idea is to look pathetic to the jury
yeah you know just look like poor
miserable if I ever get if I ever get
well you already got the mobility
scooter just show up in that show up in
the gallery full speed knock your air on
their ass this is a weird one I guess
we'll talk about it jump jumps it'd be
nice just have a short episode wanna
celebrate your birthday on the weekend
yeah Trump I don't even talk about this
Trump executive order to find Judaism as
a nationality which is weird I mean
there's a lot of Jews they don't aren't
citizens of Israel like most of them in
America at least I would say the vast
majority of Jews outside of Israel are
not citizens of Israel his order isn't
to define all Jews as a citizen of
Israel though nationality what's the
nation well yeah I guess I guess you're
right then what else would it lead back
I don't really understand what is what
is he trying to do
I'm confused with it so apparently he is
doing this to cut down on there's been
lots of boycotts on camp
such boycotting Israel and now that he's
defined them as a nationality they can
cut back on activists for they can say
that it's racist which is essentially
which is so stupid I mean it's like you
can't I mean this doesn't this isn't a
good look I hate when people always say
[ __ ] like like they say this to me all
the [ __ ] time it's like oh if you
dare criticize him it's because he's
yeah he'll pull the Jew card on you but
also the not so like not all Israeli
citizens are Jewish I'm gonna have great
pointy look a little problem here
there's problems all over the place with
this anyway he's just pandering to
really the culture oh right Israelis and
Jews I guess but I don't I don't know I
feel like secular Jews that I know all
the Jews that I know will not take
coming to this one strange the dudes not
even Jewish like where does he get off
passing declarations about yeah just
feels wrong it's like what the [ __ ] mind
your own business right yeah and I think
a lot of people have correctly pointed
out too that it's historically you know
when Jews have been defied as a race
that hasn't gone super well for them in
other countries if we it's true it's a
slippery slope just like it just seems
it's just a little icky I mean there's
already like a term anti-semitism right
like why do we need to also make it so
he's specifically creating a rule that
would prohibit protesters but again
they're not protesting the religion
they're protesting the government of
Israel which by the way the print the
Prime Minister is being charged for
corruption so there's a be able to
protest the government that's not like
saying I'm protesting Muslims I mean
even in Israel people are not agreeing
with the government and by the way it
doesn't mean that they're races are
gonna I guess themselves I don't know
that really make sense you anti-semite
I'm joy
by the way you should be able to protest
a religion - I mean you know [ __ ] that I
you can protest whatever you want it's
the right of assembly right Dan by the
letter of the law yeah I mean yeah thank
you for me I'm a this is the fate of
white supremacy as I touched on our last
episode yeah right
you know it's funny we didn't I I saw a
lot of funny comments when we when we
were addressing the kpop cancellation
they accused me of being xenophobic I'm
married to a foreigner so that's funny
right everyone said like that's so funny
and I didn't even think of it I didn't
think about it either people say that
they accuse me being white but I'm
Jewish and then that that see that one's
always hard for me I don't know I don't
know does being Jewish make me white
does make me not white it's so weird to
me this whole conversation cuz like
growing up in Israel
I consider myself white but I don't know
am I not white well funnily enough you
your origin is of like Turkey and Libya
which is the which you would be like no
I would be considered white and you
would be considered I mean like we also
Sephardic and Ashkenazi so your personal
color party because what I am but in
Israel I still don't wouldn't consider
myself not wearing role you're a person
of color for real you're African that's
sick I'm white cuz I think cuz I'm like
European descent yes and polish are not
polish a Romanian I don't [ __ ] know
Luther Wayne Ian
[ __ ] like that I guess these are white
PPO nausea and you're Sephardic which is
like African you're a person of color
I guess damn that's [ __ ] sick
let's give this a lot more Liberty when
we're having conversations about
diversity I like it I don't know if I'm
white though I always say this I think
your way and you can quote me on this if
you ask a white supremacist damn would
they say I'm Wyatt yeah I guess probably
not exactly and if you ask a person of
color in my person of color so what am i
you see according to Trump you're Jewish
that's a race you're the Jewish race
yeah see it's almost like all of this is
completely arbitrary and not really
based on anything either like the
perspective of your own culture and
upbringing
are there other ethnicities that don't
fall into one of the two categories of
white or color because okay you're
saying I'm not white and I'm not a
person of color I'm I'm Jewish which is
an ethnicity now according to Donald
Trump are there other ethnicities that
fall into an other category of not being
a person of color or white high that's I
I guess I don't really know nothing
immediately comes to mind but maybe
there is Martin listeners can help us
it's Judaism is a weird thing because
it's because it is sort of a culture and
a religion and it kind of operates on
both levels simultaneously so it it does
kind of put it in a uniquely
hard-to-define position now if you want
be there is there's another one that
we're not thinking of that that would
similarly kind of ride that line I'm
thinking hard I'm really thinking now if
you asked me I would probably consider
myself white I mean that's just kind of
my upbringing was was that of white of
whiteness you know so
[Music]
but but again like I said if you ask
white supremacists they'll say hell no
right that their boy ain't white it's
all relative like why hey what I think
of myself I my half of my family is
Jewish but it's on my father's side
which as you guys be ain't life your if
your mom is Jewish then you're
considered Jewish oh he is white yeah
my point being is that I wasn't rate I
didn't go to Temple I haven't been
raised Jewish in any way whatsoever I
don't consider not your Nazis would
whatever right that's what I was about
to say though is that I would probably
still get sent to a concentration camp
yeah why I don't know that II ain't why
she the master race I love these like
redneck ass [ __ ] and inbred tooth
missing is the white master race Zack
you are definitely not white
I'm in the same boat as you ian is
definitely white your dad is English
yeah that's that's as white as it Morris
England is the original whitey right
know what because I whose the original
whitey does that mean who's the original
whitey like what's the white race where
does that was the origin of that where's
it go I feel like the Englanders are the
original Whitey's I I don't believe so
I think it goes far further back than
that now somehow I ended up on Jew
weekly why aren't you weekly was it
saying to weekly many Jews are white
some are not get used to it get used to
it used to it
we don't want you then the whites go
we'll want the Jews they ain't white
anyways I think what we're getting out
of this is that it's all kind of an it
will defined
I don't think he was my personal caller
yeah you're pretty definitely yeah I
don't know no eel is not white piece she
straight-up African broke both of her
parents are African Turkish and Linda
Olivia Libya bro I'm telling you he was
a straight-up person of color
I'm telling you she's not white pretty
white to me but Oh was just about skin
color I mean yeah ultimately it is so
what are you was so what at what point
is the light-skinned black person white
Dan there's people who are black yeah I
mean I have the same skin tone as ela so
they're white there's a controversial
thing with that yeah they call it they
call it a passing if they're passing or
not and if somebody that's light-skinned
enough that they look white that other
people if they didn't you know that they
had like an african-american parent or
something so they're Wyatt no but for
purposes of how you're treated in
society damn I think because they don't
get the same treatment as someone who's
like really black skin versus a lighter
skin correct you know so like when they
just come to a job interview they're
almost treated like a white person even
if they're technically not exact I think
you're treated like a white person yeah
that's that I think she is to me like
you are a person of color and I as far
as the struggle goes bro she's walking
daddy L see my dad was treated as a
person of color yeah because your dad is
darks
there was no your dad was sooo that even
is that a thing in Israel he had to
change his last name when you applied to
jobs humans are so [ __ ] stupid even
in Israel together amongst each other
nobody's exempt it's like the Israel's
come together after the Holocaust and
they're still discriminating on each
other that's crazy
it's awful even said Jews go we don't
want you you're not white even the Jews
after the Holocaust it's crazy it is
crazy so you're not you're definitely a
POC and I'm a white devil I'm a pure
seed that is white privileged right you
have your prison POC you're a POS yes
I'm a POS white I will MIT though I mean
I definitely enjoy the privileges
afforded to someone who's
white in terms of the perception like
you know right that's why I was saying
earlier it's like you definitely your
your white boy
although Ethan Klein's a Jewish name so
there are people are like of Jew [ __ ]
when they see my name but that's that
maybe it was true like a few years ago
not now like when your parents maybe
when your parents were young it was
still like real anti-semitism just based
on your name nan Kelvin California yeah
or New York really because everybody's
Jewish sure nationality I'm Californian
that's the State of Israel that'd be
sick if New York and California broke
off and just made a little State of
Israel with the state of we ain't white
we mean we Jewish I don't know what do
you want for me I don't know what do you
want with me
it's Friday next week's our last week Oh
on Tuesday we're gonna do best and worst
of 2019 well yeah and then the final
episode on the 20th is Andrew Young
yahng yahng yahng yahng although you see
yeah speaking of yang that he might not
be participating in the debate after all
wait why a bunch of the candidates are
saying they're going to sit it out in
solidarity with shoulda brought this up
when we were talking about the banana
thing yeah there's like a strike going
on here in Southern California
so that's so [ __ ] they they're just
doing it to screw yang well no I I know
it's not just yang I think both Bernie
and Warren have also said that they're
not going to participate why don't you
go solo because they don't want to cross
the picket line like the this servers
service Union is is in a labor dispute
with with the venue where the debate is
supposed to take place they'll fix it
they'll get this [ __ ] together I mean
baby I'm saying it's a it's a good for
yang I may need solidarity with with
these yeah these service workers and I
think he ain't should go just be
there by himself rambling where's
everybody everybody go oh godö
three old go to 303 go to Joe 300 300 do
maybe that's the strategy they they want
Biden to just be there alone so I'll
half the talk cuz every time he opens
his mouth and I love sitting in their
laps and I love sitting in their lap and
I loved kids jumping on my lap I'm
Bernie somebody's the one person 99% of
the 2% and if you take half of the
percent and you add it to the 1% you
have 99 percent I feel like he's such a
legend like everyone likes to make fun
of him but he's a legend he's a Ledge
I'd vote for Bernie and a heartbeat and
he and incidentally he only has one
heartbeat left for the new season a curb
you watch men season finale know what
why would you say no to that because I'm
still excited about curb okay January
19th
next month my season occur will just be
coming back from our break sweet what
else I'm excited about that I'm not that
excited about Star Wars but I'll still
see it probably yeah I want that you
yeah you already bought tickets right I
actually haven't oh you guys watch the
Mandalorian oh wait there's a new one
today that I haven't watched there is a
new one and well we can't discuss that
why even bring it up because I have a
feeling that bill burrs in it yeah he's
in this one yeah I think I saw his name
trending exactly but I don't want any
spoilers obviously all Philly all Delhi
[Music]
all Billy I can barely good what thank
you it's just like this always recommend
to me you sending me something you know
what the [ __ ] you just said what the
thousands of penis fish appear on
California Beach
this thing looks like a fat cop this
fish look at the big chair
can I show that or no it scroll down
look at it on the video we can show that
yeah the second one's fine this is in
California
my girlfriend sent me that earlier today
I couldn't believe it since you think I
should show this it's so weird
is it really called a penis but dunce
wife because that's the one that you
can't show it's just a fish though I
feel like that's outrageous well I can't
show a fish just cuz it's phallic look
now even our rageous time we live in a
society it's probably okay do you
understand how insane that I can't show
a fish bro done diet you that just looks
like a fish you can do down with this
isn't that just looks like a fish that's
true the one up top look like a [ __ ]
raping car it was all veiny doing it bro
that is goddamn you know be fine you
never that story of Lorena Bobbitt the
girl who put the lady who cut her
husband's penis off and then threw it on
the side of the road and they were able
to find his penis and then sew it back
on
well imagine she threw it onto this
Beach you know he also did an adult film
after that oh my god I didn't know that
John Wayne Bobbitt was in a oh that's
incredible that he's able to still use
that thing after it was completely
severed yikes
you know I'm reading about this fish
these phallic organisms are quite common
along the west coast of North America
but they spend their whole lives in you
she burrows under the sands so a few
binge goers are aware of their existence
these are just all under my Beach I
never seen one that's so yeah this is
[ __ ] great I mean when
okay we just go to the beaches of Mandir
and just dig dig dig dig you might have
sand dabs and stuff but never this gross
oh speaking across we found a tick on
poor shredder yeah freaked me the [ __ ]
out I was scratching under his chin and
there was a bump right here under his
jaw it was like really hard to find to
him really happy in any tall grass
recently I think our backyard he just
not in our backyard
hmm what lime this I know they have Lyme
disease man call back to the curb
discussion yeah I've been thinking about
Lyme disease non-stop since last night
thank you anyway it was a huge [ __ ]
sucker and shred are so small he was
such a good boy though we think it out
with tweezers man I thought you're not
supposed to do that no you are you're
supposed to do that was to like burn
them out no that's good you definitely
don't want do that that's uh you you
actually want to remove them with
tweezers yeah burning is not as no boy
no what about the doesn't the head get
latched in well you you basically you
just close to the head as possible and
yank it out and then there was the head
was stuck in him and I was able to get
that out as well
he was such a fricking champ about it
though man he's proud of him
are you right I can't fire things yeah
it's an urban legend I've never done
that just for the record I just I've
always heard that you know and I when I
was parting his fur trying to see what
it was and I saw was a bug I was like we
both screamed we just died like there's
probably nothing and then I I put the
light of my phone on him and we looked
and screamed just there's nothing more
vile than a tick in my opinion on the
whole planet or it's just so vile and
then the fact that they have this
terrible disease I'll let you [ __ ] your
whole life up - on top of that it's just
it's so vile I wish that we could do a
tech attic genocide
they're working on that or no mosquitoes
they're trying to wipeout I yeah me I'm
really God lately
I would kill ticks first honestly yeah
there's there I guess the theory is that
mosquitoes are they won't infect they
true parasites though nothing realized
with that bullet it would be okay to get
rid of him you really wouldn't affect
anything like I I'm fighters and [ __ ] I
feel like that seems extreme too but
I've read there's all these efforts to
what about ticks can we get rid of tape
oh I think she actually does eat ticks
let's get rid of ticks that's what I'm
saying something out there he needs a
tick let's find out what eats tick so
I'm gonna praise them what oh [ __ ]
what animal eats ticks I don't know
first shrine of that my house ticks have
been found on the faces of birds [ __ ]
you ground feeding birds like chicken
and guinea fowl eat ticks their favorite
are deer ticks I'm gonna get some
chicken in the backyard there you go
mother I you actually can cause IOT as
well come and get those ants frogs
lizards and other critters that prey on
small insects near water there you go so
you can't get rid of the ticks
sorry they're needed well I'm sure they
eat other [ __ ] too you know I mean nope
just ticks as other people eat [ __ ]
mosquitoes or [ __ ] you know saying [ __ ]
alright let's wrap this up I'm done I
had fun today it up let's let's go
celebrate your birthday let's go see our
son before it's too late it's already
3:40 shoot we might miss him he goes to
bed these days like around 5:00 so but I
have a great holiday enjoy the
mandalorian enjoy okay a show we've been
watching on Hulu reprisal absurdly
secretly looks a little Twix I was like
what it's really good you heard of that
show anyone know reprisal tries I just
looked it up good
on the other hand Temptation Island is
awful you know I tried the leftovers Dan
I hated it I hey
oh really I tried one episode and I just
I haven't seen it I just heard it was
good and it's the same dude that's doing
Watchmen so Oh for real yeah that's why
I brought it up I have an actuality of
the shows so much worse huh okay well
anyway that's that thank you guys for
riding or dying with the h3 army who's
the strongest army in the world
you know it's rude oops Rio B how long
do we go for hour and a half or so there
you go how you doing now so I guess
that's it thank you guys have a great
weekend we lovely we appreciate you H
free army strongest army in the world
ride or die next week sir last week
before we go on vacation best and worst
fall by Andrew yang let's get it you
know what time it is HT army let's start
a war what our armies do they fight wars
let's get it
[Music]
[Music]
you